ça y est
il faut qu'on se bouge
tu l'as abattu mais tes mains sur la
tête
bienvenue au soleil
on va te remettre sur pied je veux
seulement arranger les choses avec
baisse
tu es vraiment doué
maman m'a dit que tu étais le meilleur
je suis dans la merde Mila après l'homme
pour qui je travaille il veut pas me
laisser partir et il me tape encore
dessus après le décès de Kevin il y
avait personne pour l'arrêter je
voudrais ne jamais l'avoir amené cette
nuit là j'ai besoin d'argent pour
commencer une nouvelle vie là tu seras
racheté auprès de moi
peux perdre du la tête
je lui dois pas de cette façon
une erreur de plus c'était fini
faites attention à vous les gars
faut aller voir la police maintenant
tu ferais mieux de la retrouver
mais avant que de te retrouver
je dois faire ça moi tout seul
j'ai ton arme j'ai dit
[Musique]